qu'est-ce qui t'apprend à jouer au golf
a peint une passion de père en fils à 4
ans seulement georges est le plus jeune
licencié du golfe isabella de plaisir
une histoire avec les clubs qui a débuté
il ya presque deux ans ça faisait un
enfin un peu moins dans les six mois
qu'il avait démarré et donc y arriver
cette période de co vide où on était
tous à la maison et là bas pendant les
après midi lorsqu'on était enfermé bas
j'ai sorti un club est vraiment j'ai
remarqué que george a été très attiré il
tapait avec moi pratiquement tous les
midis incident et des balles pour faire
des petites approche pour françois son
père georges a déjà les qualités pour
faire de lui un futur bon golfeur et ce
même en temps de plus je trouve qu'il
est il reste très concentré parce qu'ils
apprécient vraiment ça ils sont
objectifs et quand il tape une balle
c'est nous montrer qu' il a réussi donc
les très cher lorsqu'il a réussi à taper
la balle et après vraiment essayé de la
rentrée jusque dans le trou et il reste
très patient donc ça s'est vraiment bien
ici aussi autre chose c'est que quand il
rate un coup il arrive à se reconcentrer
dire c'est pas grave je vais réessayer
une deuxième fois tous les dimanches
l'apprenti golfeur vient sur le domaine
de plaisir soit pour jouer avec sa
famille soit pour renforcer ses bases
landes un cours de 45 minutes
georges a été a été licencié l'année de
ses deux ans a au cours de sa deuxième
année là il a démarré à deux ans et demi
et et on a grand plaisir à le compter
parmi nos effectifs c'est effectivement
notre plus jeune pousse et ça prouve à
tout le monde qu'il n'ya pas ya vraiment
pas de limite pour que pour commencer le
goal
contrairement à d'autres enfants du club
il a il a moins déjà besoin de ses
parents pour aller tout de suite en
cours en fait il est il espère motiver
il pas trop timide georges a déjà passé
son premier drapeau en cours et
lorsqu'on lui demande il se voit
poursuivre sa passion pour toute la vie